in the fight against coronavirus Japan
is at a critical Junction the next two
weeks are crucial in controlling the
spread here mass commuters stagger their
journeys to avoid crowds schools will
shut for most of March many officers
have already temporarily closed with
thousands of employees like taki
encouraged to work from home I'm very
worrying about the coroner virus so I'm
working from home and I'm also putting
masks and have a sanitizer and tried to
not go into the crowded place and
avoiding to Train so for Seoul rising
high bid 19 cases has triggered a state
of emergency in the northern prefecture
of Hokkaido residents are being asked to
stay indoors over the weekend while the
Olympics is still on the prime
minister's requested other big sporting
and cultural events were postponed or
canceled for the next fortnight
[Music]
coronavirus fears have already shaken
financial markets and hit some
businesses at this traditional tea
ceremony in Tokyo visitor numbers are
down these days we don't have a lot of
people from United States or England or
Europe of course so we are just worried
if we can get their tourists the number
of local infections here is rising daily
and it's now got to the point where it
is too late for Japan to totally stop
coronavirus instead the focus is on
slowing it down and limiting the number
of people that it kills this is what
Japan is desperately hoping to avoid in
neighboring South Korea infection rates
have rocketed to the highest outside
China if the Japanese acts now some
experts say containment is still
possible I think Japan is at a crucial
moment they've got some very defined
clusters outbreaks and the key is to try
to keep those outbreaks from becoming
new outbreaks or much much bigger
outbreaks Japan this government needs to
act now contact tracing asking people to
stay at home communicate communicating
to the public about what they can do to
prevent further spread while Japan ants
is a new phase in the fight this is now
a global battle coronavirus is on every
continent except Antarctica
efforts to totally stop the spread have
failed so countries must do all they can
to slow it down
Siobhan Robbins Sky News Japan